welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on information retrieval
in part two we talked about classical IR
models I hope that gave you a sense for
how IR systems work and we're now in a
good position to think about how to
evaluate them that is the topic of ir
metrics
right at the start I want to emphasize
that there are many ways in which we can
assess the quality of ir systems
of course inevitably we'll end up
focused on accuracy style metrics
they're prominent in the literature and
they are an important aspect of system
quality but there are many other things
we should think about for IR systems
particularly when they are deployed for
example in industrial context latency is
often incredibly important latency is
the time it takes to execute a single
query and in industrial context latency
constraints are often very tight users
expect low latency systems and as a
result High latency systems are
basically non-starters no matter how
accurate they are and so you often see
accuracy and latency paired as crucial
aspects of system performance
throughput is similar throughput is the
total query served in a fixed time maybe
via batch processing that's related to
latency but it could trade off against
latency you might decide to sacrifice
some per query speed in order to process
batches of examples efficiently and so
whether you favor latency or throughput
might depend on how users interact with
your system
flops is a hardware agnostic measure of
total compute resources this could be a
good holistic measure it might be hard
to measure
and kind of hard to reason about but it
could be a good summary number but we
might want to break it down into
component pieces for example disk usage
for your model or for your index that
could be an important cost especially
for our index if we're going to index
the entire web then the cost of storing
our index on disk could be very large
and we need to think about that as a
component of system quality for modern
systems maybe more pressing would be
memory usage again for the model or the
index if we need to hold the entire
index in memory to have a low latency
system that could get very expensive
very fast for example
and we could think about cost as a kind
of way to summarize all of two through
six in a way that kind of gets us
thinking holistically about the system
and about trade-offs that are inherent
in these metrics for example if we want
a really low latency system we might
need to hold everything in memory and
that could get very expensive very fast
but we could decide for example that
we're going to cut costs by making our
system smaller overall but that could
lead to a sacrifice inaccuracy and so
forth and so on given a cost constraint
we'll start thinking about trade-offs in
a way that seems very healthy and I
think more IR evaluation should be in
that holistic mode balancing all of
these considerations relative to the
interest that we have and the
constraints that we're operating under
all that said though we are now about to
focus maybe too obsessively on accuracy
style metrics let's dive into that as a
preliminary we should talk about the
kinds of data sets that you're likely to
have at your disposal they're a little
bit different from the ones that we're
accustomed to in NLP so this is worth a
review
given a query queue and a collection of
n documents d one data type that you
might have would be a complete partial
gold ranking of all the documents with
respect to your query and you would need
such rankings for every query in your
data set
that would obviously be an ordinately
expensive to do with all human labeling
so most likely if you have a data set
like this the rankings were
automatically generated via some process
it might be that you have an incomplete
partial ranking of the documents with
respect to queries so that it might be
that via some heuristics some documents
were presented to humans who then ranked
them maybe just a handful of them for
each query and that could be the basis
for inferring automatically a total
ranking but there will be some noise in
this process that goes beyond being
strictly gold labels or you'll have only
partial labels and need to think about
that
another common kind of labeling in this
space is to Simply have binary judgments
for whether or not documents in our
Corpus are relevant or not to the given
query that's very common to see
this could be based on human labeling
but it could also be based on a weak
supervision heuristic for example
whether each document contains the query
that we're interested in as a substring
that would obviously be very noisy but
we found in practice that that kind of
weak supervision heuristic can be
powerful when it comes to training good
IR systems
and then maybe the most relevant data
type for us as we think about neural IR
systems in particular is the one given
in item four here here we have a tuple
consisting of one positive document for
our query and one or more negative
documents for our query that can be a
device for both training IR systems and
for evaluating them
so with those data types in place let's
start to think about the metrics
themselves we'll start with the simplest
ones which are success and reciprocal
rank a common ingredient for both of
them is what I've called rank here
for a ranking D of our documents we say
that the rank for a query in that
ranking is an integer and that is the
position of the first relevant document
for the query in our ranking the first
one
and on that basis we can just define
success at K we pick some value K and
then we say for our query and our
ranking the value for Success at K is
one if the rank for the query in our
ranking is less than or equal to K
otherwise zero so a binary judgment
and then the reciprocal rank is similar
RR at k for a query and a document
ranking is one over the rank for that
query in the ranking if the rank is less
than or equal to K otherwise zero so
this is identical to success except
whereas success we have one now we have
one over the actual rank value but we
mapped to zero all cases where rank is
below k
and then mrr at K is a common metric
that you see in the literature and
that's simply the average over multiple
queries for the RR at K values
let's get a deeper feel for these
metrics by looking at some examples and
I'm going to use these rankings as
running examples here's the first one
this is a ranking of six documents
relative to some fixed query queue and a
star indicates that the document was
judged relevant to the query
so in this ranking the first two are
considered relevant and the final one in
the ranking is also considered relevant
here's a second ranking in this ranking
again it's the same three stars but they
appear in different positions now the
first relevant document is at position
two and the other two are in positions
five and six
and then for document ranking three
again same three stars but now they're
at positions three four and five in the
ranking
before we even think about metrics you
might step back and ask yourselves which
one of these rankings is the best and it
might not be so obvious it might depend
on perspective for example document
ranking one looks really good because
the first two documents in the ranking
are relevant
however it has the third star all the
way down in last place
whereas just for a comparison if you
look at ranking three all of its stars
are low in positions three four and five
but at least it didn't put any of them
in last place and then document ranking
two might look intermediate between
those two extremes
so obviously different metrics will be
sensitive to different Notions of
quality in that sense
and it might be hard to decide at priori
which kind of quality we're actually
seeking it's going to be all about
trade-offs and reflecting on those high
level considerations
let's return to success in reciprocal
rank how do they do success at two for
document ranking one given our fixed
query is one and that's because there is
some relevant document at or above
position two in this ranking doesn't
really matter in this case that there
are two of them
same thing for ranking two we get a
value of one because there is a star at
or above position two
whereas ranking three gives us success
at two of zero and that's because there
are no stars at or above position two in
the ranking
the reciprocal rank values at two will
be similar but a little bit more nuanced
the rr2 for the first ranking is one and
that's because it's one over one so we
have
our first relevant document in position
one
the the denominator there is the rank
whereas for ranking two it's one over
two and that's because the first
relevant document now is in position two
here
whereas for document three as before we
get an RR at two of zero because there
are no stars at or above two in the
ranking
let's move now to precision and recall
these are classic IR metrics and they're
going to be more nuanced than success
and RR because they are going to be
sensitive to multiple stars for success
and RR we really only cared about one
star whereas now we're going to care
about the full set of them that we have
two preliminary Concepts first the
return set for a ranking at Value K is
the set of documents in the ranking at
or above k
and the relevant set for a query given a
document ranking is simply the set of
all documents that are relevant to the
query that is all the ones in my
notation that have stars attached to
them anywhere in the ranking
then we can define precision at a
relevant value get a chosen value K the
Precision at k
here the numerator is the return set
intersected with the relevant set and
the denominator is the value k
this is kind of intuitive in terms of
precision if we think about the values
at or above K as the guesses that we
made with Precision we're saying how
many of those guesses were good ones
and recall is a kind of duel of that
recall has the same denominator the
recall at K is the return set
intersected with the relevant set the
number of those divided by in this case
the number of relevant documents
and so this is kind of like saying if
the set of things at or above K are our
guesses how many of the relevant ones
actually burbled up to be at or above k
kind of dual of precision
let's see how these values play out in
terms of our three rankings we'll do
Precision first Precision at two in our
first ranking is two out of two
because we set k at or above 2 and both
of those documents are relevant
for ranking two it's one out of two
because again we have two set two
documents in our denominator and only
one in our numerator only one relevant
document there
whereas for ranking three Precision at
two is zero out of two
let's look at the recall the recall at
two for our first ranking is two out of
three recall the denominator there is
three because there are three relevant
documents three stars and two of them
are at or above K so that's quite an
impressive value it's like the max there
for document ranking two it's one out of
three again we have three relevant
documents in the denominator and only
one of them is at or above k
and then finally as you could predict
for ranking three it's zero out of three
because there are no relevant documents
at or above two here
so that kind of reproduces more or less
the ranking that we saw for success and
reciprocal rank
but here's a Twist suppose we set our
value of K to 5 whereas before it was 2.
now we get this set of precision and
recall values and the noteworthy thing
here is that having set it at five
document ranking three is now clearly in
the lead and it's in the lead because it
didn't put anything in position six so
it got Precision at five out of three
out of five
and it got recall at five of three out
of three whereas both of these are less
good and that shows you
how important the value of K was to our
overall assessment of quality and we
should think when we use these metrics
about what we're doing when we set K and
how it might affect our assessment of
ranking quality
average Precision is a nice alternative
because it's less sensitive to the value
of K and we just saw how impactful that
can be average Precision for a query
relative to a document ranking is kind
of intuitively spelled out like this for
the numerator we're going to get
Precision values for every step where
there is a relevant document every place
where there is a star and we sum those
up and then the denominator is the set
of relevant documents
so here's how this plays out again using
those same three rankings that we had
before we have relevant documents for
ranking one at one two and six so those
are the three Precision values that we
check and we simply sum those up to get
two out of five over three
for document ranking two we sum up the
same things but now at positions two
five and six and we get 1.4 divided by
three and then for D3 we get relevant
position we have relevant documents at
three four and five those are our
Precision values and they sum to 1.43
and this is noteworthy because document
ranking one is the clear winner even
though we have no sensitivity to K
anymore but in fact ranking three inched
ahead of ranking two in this metric
which is something that we hadn't really
seen before except for that one case
where we set K low for precision and
recall
this is nice because we don't have the
sensitivity Decay anymore we've kind of
abstracted over all the different values
we could have chosen and we still have
this numerator here keeping track of the
number of relevant documents
that's a sampling of common metrics
there are of course many more but
they'll follow similar patterns let's
step back here and ask which metric
should you be using and you can probably
anticipate my answer at this point there
is no single answer let's just think
about some trade-offs
for you is the cost of scrolling through
K passages low for your users say or for
you then maybe success at K is
fine-grained enough because all you need
to do is find a relevant one in that set
of K documents
are there multiple relevant documents
per query
if so success and reciprocal rank are
probably going to be too coarse grain
because they're not sensitive to having
these multiple relevant documents
is it more important to find every
relevant document if so favor recall
is it more important to review only
relevant documents if so favor precision
right this would be a case where the
cost of missing something is high
but the cost of review is low
down here maybe the cost of review could
be high but we don't really pay too much
if we miss things we just need to find a
few relevant exemplars and so we can
favor Precision in that case
F1 at K is the harmonic mean of the
Precision and recall values at K and
that can be used where there are
multiple relevant documents but their
relative order above K doesn't matter
that much and so you've decided to
balance precision and recall
average Precision of all the metrics I
showed you will give the finest grain
distinctions of all the metrics that we
discussed it's sensitive to rank and
precision and recall and so if you don't
have very much information and you would
like to make fine-grained distinctions
among different rankings you've
predicted average Precision may be a
very good choice
but as I said at the start I would love
for us to break out of the mold of
thinking only about accuracy
to get us thinking in that direction
what I have here is what we call a
synthetic leaderboard in this paper that
we recently completed and we just
assembled from the literature a lot of
different systems and tried to figure
out from the papers what they had done
in terms of Hardware
accuracy here mrr and latency
and if you zoom in on the mrr column
that is the accuracy column I think it
emerges that you should pick like one of
these Colbert systems or this one here
but
for example The Colbert systems to
achieve that mrr need pretty heavy duty
hardware for gpus whereas if we go up to
some of these split splade systems
they're kind of comparable in terms of
quality but they have fewer resources
that they require in terms of hardware
and then within those blade systems you
can start to think about the trade-offs
relative to hardware and latency and
that again gets you thinking in a
totally new way about which of these
systems is the best
and that's the kind of thinking that I
want to encourage here's another
perspective on this this is also from
that same paper we've got cost along the
x-axis here and a measure of accuracy
along the y-axis
this is bm25 down at the bottom it's
very inexpensive
but it is very ineffective as well
for essentially the same cost you could
have a huge jump in your accuracy in
your mrr if you just pick that small BT
splade system that's given in green
and you could go up a little bit yet
again with a slight cost increase by
picking the medium model and then even
just a slight cost increase after that
and you get the BT splayed large model
huge jump in performance with hardly any
cost increase whereas correspondingly
this kind of picture makes it seem like
you wouldn't pick this and system
because it's both expensive and less
good in terms of accuracy than some of
these more inexpensive systems and more
generally this is sometimes called the
Pareto Frontier of systems given the two
things we've decided to measure some
systems are strictly dominating some
other systems
but of course there may be other
dimensions to this that would cause ants
to pull ahead and so we need to think
holistically again and this is just
reinforcing the notion that there is one
there isn't one fixed answer to the
question of system quality there are
lots of dimensions and lots of
trade-offs to consider ultimately